today in our city the end of the chapter
that has brought our people so much pain
and so much fear over this last five
years the pain was because we all
watched a human being die before our
eyes on a video watched a man who should
be still alive today and it was so
difficult for all of us to reconcile
what we saw with what we must believe
about law enforcement our officers are
here to protect us to keep us safe and
yet we watched a man die an honor man it
caused so many people to ask what if
that was my brother right there in that
situation what if that was my son what
if that was my father what if that was
me
the fear was because for a long time
people wondered if we would be left
without justice the place that we had
turned for generations to place that was
synonymous with making things right
failed us the United States Department
of Justice absent and unwilling to act
even to come to any decision for five
long years but today we have finally
seen justice done today we saw the
NYPD's own disciplinary process act
fairly and impartially for years people
have questioned whether a police
department can provide justice for all
and we watched a fair and impartial
trial we watched an objective decision
by a Deputy Commissioner of the NYPD
affirmed by the first deputy
commissioner and affirmed by the police
commissioner justice has been done and
that decision has resulted in the
termination of officer Pantaleo for the
garner family that has gone through so
much agony for so long and has waited
this long just to have one trial finally
conclude with a decision I hope today
brings some small measure of closure
today will not bring Eric garner back
but I hope it brings some small measure
of closure and peace to the garner
family
now we have to look beyond this tragedy
because our city is at a pivotal moment
and I'm reminded of what dr. King taught
us paraphrasing him in moments of
suffering or difficulty there are two
ways we can respond we can react with
bitterness and division and we can be
trapped by the sins of our past or we
can transform the suffering into
progress we can find redemption we can
use moment like this to turn it into
something better to move ourselves
forward and that is for all of us to do
we can't have the illusion that someone
else creates a better society that is
for all of us to do and we have to do it
we have to all create something better
and I see this as a sacred mission we
all must take on we must devote
ourselves to this simple goal that no
person no family no community should
ever go through the agony that we've all
experienced here over these last years
it should never happen again in this
city or this country that is the only
goal that is acceptable let this be the
last tragedy to actually get there we
all have to confront our history
honestly
and it's not a history that we can
always be proud of it's something that
we have to own up to and deal with but I
know that the NYPD of today is a
different institution than it was just a
few years ago I know the NYPD has
changed profoundly I know that members
of the NYPD learned the lessons of this
tragedy they acted on it they did
something about it
it is a beginning but we have a lot more
to do and the change has to get deeper
and deeper and that is not a top-down
enterprise that is for all of us to do